[Música]
tanta emoción alrededor de eso
para esta elección presidencial, lo que significa que
Lo discutimos, lo sé con mis amigos.
aquí no estamos un poco ansiosos pero
aquí todavía estamos mirando quiénes son nuestros
toma nota de las opiniones políticas que tenemos nosotros mismos y
intentamos leer los programas pero
es cierto que mi eso es todo en ese momento
emocionante y al mismo tiempo
si ambos angustiantes
[Música]
entonces es como un funcionamiento
trueno podremos deslizarnos y ser
así que dejé de rechazar el
sugerencia o desplazarse hacia la derecha
para poder validar la propuesta si
estamos de acuerdo con lo que proponen
en secreto creo que me ayudará
porque todavía hay una verdadera confusión entre mis
opción, pero sé en cualquier caso en qué
don que valor me encontrare
Me parece útil esta aplicación
sobre todo para informarle con mayor precisión
sobre lo que piensa cada uno de los candidatos
pero complica entre comillas tu
elección final
Creo que en las próximas elecciones
Voy a hacer la misma votación que hice allí.
hace cinco años la aplicación no cambiará
gran cosa
está congelado, ya no se toma como un hobby
como algo divertido
[Música]
en los pocos países donde ha habido
estudios donde la gente usó mucho
este tipo de aplicación no ha visto eso
tuvo un impacto en la
votos
[Música]
están obligados como todos los demás a
respetar un cierto número de cosas
si hay datos personales son
Di quién te identifica en relación con
tus opiniones politicas
debe haber un requisito para
consentimiento cuando explicas
claramente el uso de datos allí
A menudo también existe un principio de finalidad.
es decir que si es por ejemplo
para la campaña electoral no podemos
utilizar datos más allá de la campaña
electoral
[Música]